a re-imagined version of the classic
film The Color Purple is about to take
the World by storm 40 years after the
original hit theaters between a massive
new cast new songs and some familiar
faces who set out to correct The
Originals mistakes there's a lot to look
forward to let's take a look at all the
behind thes scenes details about the
color purple it's already clear there
will be some major differences between
the original film and the Remake which
in itself is a good enough reason to
make a new version it's also a musical
unlike the original the trend of turning
successful films into musicals for the
stage is far from New but this trend of
turning them back into new film
adaptations May begin booming in
Hollywood with the upcoming movie
adaptation of the Mean Girls musical
which of course was an adaptation of the
original film in the new color purple we
want to connect with the younger
generation the trailer advertises this
new adaptation as a bold new take so
it's sure to bring the story to new
audiences a story which director Blitz
Baza woule says one of the cornerstones
of culture certainly Black Culture put a
little modern twist to it was still
capturing the essence of what this film
means you may know Fantasia burino from
her American Idol wi in 2004 or her
Grammy Award and numerous nominations
that followed she was known for her
showstopping rendition of summertime
from the musical porgi and best while on
American Idol so it's no wonder that she
was a SHO win for the musical theater
World The Color Purple originally an
award-winning 1982 novel by Alice Walker
was adapted into a 1985 film directed by
Steven Spielberg the story was then
adapted into a musical which hit
Broadway in 2005 with lesons as the
leading role cely Fantasia took over in
2007 and she's reprising her role in the
movie adaptation yet making her major
Motion Picture debut as cely wasn't easy
after her time playing the role on
Broadway she and I are a lot ofik she
and I went through some of the same
thing how she related to the heavy roll
made her time on Broadway incredibly
draining I did s in 2007 and Broadway
and I hated it because I was so young
and I was still going through so much
I'm glad that this time around I said
yes cuz of course I said no taking on
the role wasn't nearly as easy as it may
have been for others because Fantasia
knew just how draining it was I remember
playing when I was younger and it was
heavy and I said no I'm happy now I'm
married and I want to go back there when
she learned about Blitz Baza wou's New
Vision though she changed her tune was
given sely and Imagination and I said
I'll take it Fantasia believed that this
new iteration of cely was something the
world needed to see she needed to speak
and the the Young Generation needed to
hear and and everyone woman needed to
see it and when Fantasia chose to say
yes she said yes to all all of it
including the stunts she wanted to make
sure that she fully embodied cely in all
that she did so she turned down the
offer for a stunt double for her scenes
that involved altercations Danielle
Brooks is also reprising her role after
mastering it on Broadway Brooks played
Sophia in the 2015 Revival which earned
her a Tony Award nomination Brooks says
she had a different perspective when
taking on the role nearly a decade later
for the film and she was thankful that
Oprah Winfrey who played the role in the
original film was looking out for her on
this production I actually asked her in
our hour and a half conversation I said
can you pray for me and she did it's
clear that Brooks is thrilled to be
reprising her role so if you going to
get anybody to pray for you it's better
be over with and my life has changed
completely ever since and she's also
thrilled that the movie is coming out
when it is getting to play sopia has
been such a joy getting to do it from
the theater now to film for the whole
world aside from the leading ladies who
are taking their roles from stage to
screen the rest of the cast is just as
star studded Hal Bailey plays young
netti and carara plays adult netti
Taraji P Henson plays Suge Avery and
Coleman Domingo plays Mister just to
name a few some of the cast members
aren't the only familiar forces in the
film Steven Spielberg Oprah Winfrey and
Quincy Jones are all producers on the
new adaptation Jones also produced the
original film spiel ber directed the
original and Oprah made her film debut
in it as Sophia working on the remake of
a film you were a part of 40 years prior
is surely a unique experience for Steven
Spielberg though it's a chance to change
something he wasn't happy with in the
first iteration in the original film
cely has a brief romantic relationship
with Suge Avery after which cely has
deep feelings for Suge that aren't
Mutual Spielberg wished that he had
further explored this romance in his
film so being a part of the new version
allows him to change things that he
wished were different in the original
what changes are you hoping to see in
this reimagined version let's talk about
it in the comments and for more videos
like this one like And subscribe to the
things